I'd like each of you to get up and tell us a five minutes story about your summer
At some point you make a choice about who you are what you want
Hey, I'm Roo. I'm an addict.
You're about to start a brand new chapter
Some new girl in town and I think you're gonna be friends with. I'm roo. I'm Jules.
Suddenly the whole world goes dark and nothing else matters, but the person standing in front of you
I'm envious of your generation. You guys don't care as much about the rules. They're just reaching for something
To make it all seem meaningful
Every time I feel good, I think it'll last forever, but it doesn't
Nothing lasts forever
I've got an Idea. Should I be concerned?
You think if I went to rehab I'd stay clean?
I mean ain't that the point?
If could be a different person, I would.
Babycakes take your time, you're delicate.
I owe it to everyone I Love to at least try and change.